yeah ethically author of the book dear
mr. Buffett what do you think of money
what do I think of money you know I'm
glad you asked that question because
this is all about money and whether or
not Washington protected our money and
what has happened to our money over the
past few years money was nothing more
than something we human beings created
in order to enhance our probability of
survival so money is a very important
means of exchange you know in what Beck
when we created money the reason we did
it is because let's say I was growing
wheat well I would have to exchange my
wheat in the marketplace for various
goods and services that I needed and if
somebody didn't need wheat at the moment
it would be hard for me to barter my
wheat for something else so we created
money as a representation that I have
this week behind it I'll give you this
piece of paper or this coin and someone
else will take that piece of paper or
coin for your goods because they know
that I have wheat backing my coins and
we created money to make it easier for
us to trade goods and to enhance our
ability to get the things that we need
to survive to make life better for
everyone
so money isn't an evil thing money is
actually a good thing that we humans
created and that's why it's all the more
important for our government to take a
key responsibility in protecting the
value of our money so that it's accepted
everywhere in exchange for goods and
services and so that we the population
can create that from the value that
we've created what's been your own
relationship to money in your life my
own relationship to money the way I view
it may be different than a lot of other
people I've always viewed it as a means
of Independence and that may just be
coming from being a woman growing up in
the United States I viewed money as a
way to provide security and freedom
I was never all about accumulating vast
quantities of goods I wanted money so
that I would have the freedom to do the
things that I enjoy doing in life
and to provide opportunities for the
people in my life that are important
where do you live I live in Chicago how
do you make your money I make my money
from intellectual capital so I used to
work more with my hands now I work more
with my mind I was a former chemical
engineer and I worked in chemical
companies and then an oil refinery to
make a living now I make my living
primarily by analyzing things figuring
things out mainly for large financial
institutions cheaply people that I
worked for in the past only people that
I know and know well and I make it in
the tongue-twisting products that
brought the global economy to its knees
things like credit derivatives
collateralized debt obligations things
that most Americans haven't heard of but
these are the things that got into our
financial markets and were abused and
misused so the global financial economy
now some people say it has had a heart
attack and I say no it's actually more
like appendicitis where you have toxic
assets leaking into the system and
basically crippling it and what we're
doing right now instead of fixing the
problem is we're prescribing some very
potent addictive painkillers and that's
not the way to go when the economy is
having an appendix attack what word
would you use to describe the way you
feel about what's going on I have some
complicated feelings about what's going
on Brian because I'm sure that there are
many people who believe that they are
doing the right thing but what is going
on now is misguided and the policies
that we've adopted will only make our
pain and suffering drag out and it has
the what's going on now as we are
delaying fixing the problem we haven't
created any transparency so we're
covering up the problem and all of our
policies seem designed to give comfort
to the financial system and in some
cases unwarranted comfort and undeserved
comfort actually that this is financial
but I was looking for a word like you
know we here
the commentators yes they're like they
know they hear like I'm scared
are you scared hey are you scared about
what's going on we should be we should
be very worried I don't want to scare
the American people let me first say and
this is a very important thing that I
don't think has been stressed enough to
the American people if you have money in
a bank and you are underneath the FDIC
threshold of 250,000 per individual for
a married couple that would be two
hundred and fifty thousand each plus
another two hundred fifty thousand
jointly for a total of seven hundred and
fifty thousand most Americans are
underneath this limit your deposits are
just fine your deposits would be just
fine
even if your bank went into receivership
your your deposits are fine you don't
have to have a run on the bank you will
get your money the FDIC is doing a very
good job with that so but most people
are afraid and concerned because of the
wealth effect they have seen their net
worth dramatically decline their 401 K
accounts the value of their home their
job security in some cases or their job
so yes I think as a country we should
take this very seriously and fear isn't
a very useful emotion but if you are
feeling that way you want to harness it
in a constructive way
write your Congressman write your
Senators tell them how you feel about
what's going on inform yourself read the
papers take that energy and put it to
some good use because we Americans are
not a critical phase in our democracy
our democracy has been diluted by the
effects of the actions that we've taken
to try to get out of this financial
crisis by the way you think the $250,000
limit will be extended beyond the end of
this year I hope it will be the old
limit was a hundred thousand dollars and
that's a big difference isn't it and I
think part of the reason of increasing
the limit was so that people wouldn't
withdraw funds above the limit but also
to attract money that was fleeing from
money market accounts because money
market accounts started liquidating
assets out of the fear that they may
have toxic
assets and people were taking money out
of money market funds that money had to
go somewhere and it was a better idea to
have that money go to the bank that
needed deposits and if more money was
going to go to the banks we needed to
raise that limit that guarantee limit so
I hope that limit will be extended but
Americans should watch that if you are
above the hundred thousands limit and
you know you're close to the two hundred
fifty thousand won that you'll want to
watch that very carefully to see if
those guarantees will be extended even
though it appears that the government is
willing to just willy-nilly print money
to prevent any bank from going into
receivership which i think is a
galactically bad idea this book dear mr.
Buffett is which book for you
what's the number well if you count the
second editions of my other books that
would be the fifth book my first book
was on credit derivatives and people
have heard a lot about that these days
they've they've added to the risk in the
system by providing leverage and
providing opacity so a lot of bad guys
pulled a lot of shenanigans using credit
derivatives which increased risk in the
system and increased people's ability to
borrow in a hidden way so that there was
a lot of debt in the system that was
invisible and banks themselves were
often running invisible hedge fund the
legacy investment banks were running
invisible hedge funds but so where are
our major banks and that includes JP
Morgan Citigroup Bank of America our
largest banks so it added a lot of risk
to the system and people are in denial
about their ability to manage those
those things and also collateralized
debt obligations which are include these
packages of mortgage securities some of
which were overrated and overpriced the
minute they came to market and that if
that wasn't enough investment banks
we're creating these things and their
financial meth labs knowingly selling
things that they knew or should have
known were overrated and overpriced and
it didn't stop there they went one
better in 2007 when it was clear that
this activity should be shut down
because
we had mortgage lenders failing
throughout the country instead of
shutting down these financial meth labs
investment banks sped up they
accelerated the bad deals they were
bringing to market and these now weren't
just bad deals many of them were just
phony securitizations with no other
purpose than to hide losses I mean I'm
going to ask you to do this simple thing
of defining a lot of this language in
credit derivatives who invented that
term I don't know who invented the term
it's been around for maybe 15 years but
credit derivatives didn't start growing
until the late 90s and and in 2000
that's when we saw really this huge
growth spurt
any idea who started as lie I mean
deserve what JPMorgan Chase was in the
forefront of pushing credit derivatives
technology and it wasn't meant to be a
bad thing originally no credit
derivatives what is that well if you
have a bond let's say and somebody you
have the debt of someone a government
bond or a corporate bond you expect to
get paid back par at maturity and you
have credit risk you put money upfront
you expect to get your money back and
the maturity of the bond in between you
get coupon payments but let's say you
wanted to protect your investment in a
bond and you were worried about the
credit you could buy credit protection a
credit derivative it's not a bond it's
derived from a bond so it's a derivative
and it's a credit derivatives you're
trying to protect your credit so you
could say I'll pay you all of my coupon
or part of my coupon to protect my money
that I will get paid back at maturity so
it was an idea originally of hedging or
transferring risk it was meant to be a
good thing and the in all candor banks
created it because they wanted to get
loan risk off their balance sheet but
they had put loans on their balance
sheet at prices that didn't make sense
so they realized if we could persuade
Basel and persuade the Fed that we could
create this big pocket that had
virtually zero risk called a super
senior tranche
then we don't have to pay much of
anything for that protection and we can
basically transfer most of the risk of
these mispriced loans off of our balance
sheet that's how it started okay you've
said a lot of things that the average
person is going and I'll consider myself
in that all right category a super
senior tranche right we're supposed to
be super safe
what's a trot trot now if I take a
package of mortgages and I put them all
together in a pool I can create a little
business you could say that's going to
pay cash out from all these mortgages
that are paying their interest rate
every month and their principal and so a
tranche of this pool of mortgages would
be let's say Brian you love risk and you
would say look Jan I don't know if any
of these mortgages will go into
foreclosure but I'm willing to take the
risk of let's say the first four percent
of the mortgages in this pool whoever
they are if they default I'll take that
risk but I want to get paid more and
I'll say okay Brian you have the
riskiest tranche call the equity tranche
someone else doesn't like that much risk
but they say Brian took the first 4% of
the mortgages to foreclose if any I'll
take the next four to eight percent and
I want to get paid a little bit less
than Brian but you know not nothing I
want to you know I have a fair amount of
risk that's the second tranche and so on
up the line until you get to what was
supposedly this super safe super senior
where basically they say we're protected
because all of these other guys all of
these other tranches are taking losses
before I take a loss all these tranches
by the way are not backed up by the
Federal Deposit Insurance Corporation
not at all
no this risk was purely on the investor
many of whom were sophisticated
investors what happened to the because I
was growing up the simple process of
going into a bank and getting a mortgage
paying them I remember there 9% 10%
loans yeah and the bank just keeping
that mortgage why did they have to go to
this business of securitizing this all
right now you know Brian you've hit
the key problem on the head and that is
if you had gone to a bank a bank
generally knows you they know your where
you live they you know maybe even new
people in your neighborhood they
basically had an idea of whether or not
your job was secure they could verify
your savings you general handle your
savings with the same bank that you got
your mortgage from so they knew who you
were your character your credit your
capacity to pay and that was a good idea
when we had found lending practices at
banks packaging mortgages together was a
really good idea because people would
put 20% down they their total debt was
no more than 36 percent of their income
we had a number of things that we looked
for for a good solid mortgage loan
that's prudent lending we really need to
get back to and we're nowhere near that
yet but the reason that was a good idea
is because it allows you to buy a house
you could borrow money that's called
leverage and you could pay for your
house over time people used to have
parties when they paid off their
mortgage it was supposed to be a reason
to celebrate not a reason to borrow more
money and take more money out of your
house it was a very good idea and those
securitizations those packages of loans
were pretty safe stuff it was a good
idea the housing market was stable now
everyone in the mortgage business took
the business very seriously because you
wanted homeowners to succeed you wanted
them to be able to pay back to give
somebody a mortgage loan that they can't
pay back is not doing them a favor to
allow everybody access to that kind of
lending is not a good idea you aren't
doing somebody a favor if you put them
in a house overnight and they have to
default on their mortgage all you've
done is give them a mortgage loan you
haven't helped them buy a house if you
were to find that person or group of
people that decided at one point that
this was a very quick way of making lots
of money yeah what would you put your
what tail what donkey would you put your
the tail on you know there are a lot of
donkeys out there to put the tail on
there
a number of mortgage lenders that grew
up across the country largely
unregulated so you had mortgage lenders
like a mirror first like countrywide
like new century those are the larger
ones but you had a number of smaller
ones throughout the country we've had
hundreds fail and these people didn't
necessarily know the borrower's they
were all about churning mortgages in
order to earn fees now we could have
stopped this early on but it was
investment banks not our traditional
banking system but investment banks and
by them I mean all five of them Goldman
Sachs Morgan Stanley Merrill Lynch
Lehman Brothers Bear Stearns who got
involved in saying will package these up
now instead of the banks and will sell
them to investors but they were giving
an incentive to mortgage lenders to say
look we'll give anybody along because we
can earn fees and there won't be very
much scrutiny about what we're doing and
how we're doing it so if you want if you
can't afford the house you know you can
get a mortgage on 80 percent of the
value of the home and we'll give you a
debt an additional loan to be able to
buy a house so basically people were
buying homes with effectively no money
down and they were buying homes they
couldn't afford now in some cases people
were buying homes they could afford and
they were slammed with risky mortgage
products that they didn't expect when
closing occurred so we had a combination
of things one were people who saw they
could exploit the system mortgage
brokers who basically wanted to earn
these people who wanted to borrow and
buy too much house that they knew they
couldn't afford hoping that housing
prices would go up and bail them out in
the third category which is a very sad
category and those people who were
actively misled these loans were
presented as if they were a gift and
they were really a Trojan horse loan
that people read rode into bankruptcy
they rode to their financial ruin so
people whose credit maybe was already
shaky or whose financial situation was
shaky basically thought well maybe I can
make it you know mortgage brokers are
telling me it's okay
they're telling me that my interest rate
will stay low when the reality was it
would pop up to the stratosphere and
their principal balance in some cases
could even increase so we had a
combination of riskier mortgage products
made to homeowners who are taking on too
much debt in the first place and that's
a formula for disaster we stabilized our
housing market but as you know we can
and you tell me what you think but we we
can I can show you video right now of
both the Republicans and the Democrats
saying over the last 20 years we want
everybody in the house people breaking
about in politics the percentage of
people in the United States that own
their house or at least you're buying
their house is there a culprit out there
is there a group of people in politics
or in investment banking
can you name anybody it's that the weak
or I'm not sure you even want to blame
anybody but as hot and this is a bottom
part happen again this is a bipartisan
problem we you have people like Barney
Frank and Chris Dodd who have been dude
proponents of this homeownership and big
proponents of Fannie and Freddie
lowering their lending standards these
are our big indirect mortgage lenders
because they buy mortgages from people
who have who have been the mortgage
lenders and it has destabilized our
housing market if you deviate from
prudent lending and you put too much
leverage in the system and you have
individuals putting on too much debt
it's a formula for failure what happens
is you get a bubble in prices and as
those prices come down you see is Warren
Buffett might say when the tide goes out
you see who's been swimming naked and
there are a lot of nudists in America
right now unfortunately their efforts
were misguided and if this is a way to
buy votes it's a really bad way to do it
you know if you look at the Board of
Directors of Freddie and Fannie both
Republicans from politics and Democrats
from politics served on the board all
through those years as the people
running them we're taking millions of
dollars out now how did that well
there's been a lot of crony capitalism
and I think Americans need to pay
attention
we have financial oligarchy this has
been said in many places and I
completely agree with that these people
practically have Tim Geithner on
speed-dial and I was hopeful that when
somebody like Obama came in that there
would be meaningful change if anything
the situation has gotten worse but this
is bipartisan you'll notice that
President George Bush when he was in
office he elevated Roland Arnall who was
the head of America that had been
involved in alleged mortgage fraud
massive sued by almost every state in
the Union and he was elevated to the
position of ambassador to the
Netherlands the Netherlands didn't even
like it there were articles in the
Netherlands saying it was reprehensible
because it sent a very bad public policy
message not only can you do things that
are against the American interest and
can help to stabilize the housing market
are a huge piece of our economy but you
can be rewarded with an ambassadorship
it was incredible and Congress approved
it so this is a bipartisan mishmash that
we have with people whose interests are
not serving the American people
primarily they're primarily serving the
and protecting the financial sector and
we've bailed out a lot of bad guys a lot
of bad guys a lot of people and I heard
a mentioned Paul Volcker was talking in
Toronto and he said that well people
relied on models and this was a
mathematical error and I have been a big
critic of model models over the years
and I have to tell you this was not a
model issue this was a management issue
we had people who knew or should have
known they were selling things that were
value destroying securitizations and
their sale provided money to mortgage
lenders who were originating fraudulent
loans in some cases and in other cases
loans that were brand new risky products
that were overrated by complicit rating
agencies and I knew this sitting in
Chicago and I didn't say it after the
fact I said it in real time and you know
I gave examples of this deal
should not close this feels ridiculous
and has more red flags for fraud than
anything I've ever seen
it's a classic situation for fraud this
deal shouldn't close it's going to
crumble and I gave morning after warning
about that and started speaking out
about it in public so there weren't any
outliers like model outliers and
mathematics there were just a lot of
outright liars and we have not held
people accountable for those in fact
we've been bailing them out let me go
over as some of your own background
where were you born
I was born in Chicago but in my adult
life I've lived in the in Iran for a
year in New York and London in the
financial business working primarily for
investment banks and in some large bank
what part of Chicago at the south side
of Chicago not to go to high school
there I did yes where'd you go to
college I went to college in Chicago to
an engineering school Illinois Institute
of Technology and you got a chemical
engineering degree Chemical yes why what
was your life like and why did you want
to be a chemical engineer I always liked
math and I liked chemistry a lot and my
father had died when I was 12 years old
and I thought about well medical school
or something in the sciences but with a
four-year chemical engineering degree
you can get a job and support yourself
and that was in the mid 70s when we were
just coming out of a recession so it was
foremost in my mind that I wanted to be
able to be self-sufficient but then I
got married right out of college moved
to worked as a chemical engineer moved
to Iran for a year came back to the
United States and worked my way through
the Graduate School of Business at the
University of Chicago then I moved to
New York for a number of years more than
10 years and then to London and worked
in the financial services industries so
I know many of the key players who were
involved in the mortgage meltdown I knew
them personally and still know many of
the people who are involved now and
what's going on you married an Iranian
by the name of Tavakoli that's correct
that's my ex-husband's name and where
did you meet in I met him in school an
engineering school
how long were you married I was married
for five years and what did you learn
about living in Iran well you know I
want year was it on July I lived in Iran
before during after the Shah was
overthrown for that that period of time
and I left Iran around three months
after home Amy returned and for me it
was an eye-opening experience to observe
why do people believe the things that
they believe and I had even challenged
my own beliefs not not my beliefs but I
challenged the way that I look at the
world and how that can appear funny to
other people my ex-husband was a born a
Muslim but he didn't practice none of
his family was very secular so they
didn't pray or they weren't religious
yet of course religion is a very
important part of Iran as a whole and I
remember when we were living in the
United States even something like our
practices for burying our dead
there was a wake for one of the
professors at the Illinois Institute of
Technology and I had a class to attend I
couldn't attend the wake with my
ex-husband I went separately but he came
back from the wake white as a sheet and
he said you didn't tell me you didn't
warn me about this and I said warn you
about what he said Janet was horrible it
was just horrible
his body was laying right there and
everybody went up to the body and was
touching the body and talking about how
wonderful he looked and he didn't look
wonderful so for him it was a traumatic
experience and something is our simple
customs can appear to an outsider to be
traumatic and he lived in the United
States for a number of years he had gone
to his undergraduate in the United
States and then was getting his PhD when
I met him so it wasn't as if he was new
to the United States it's just that even
a simple custom can throw a curveball to
foreigners and when I looked at the Iran
and a country I was mindful of that when
I was viewing their customs and their
practices but I have to say that the
thing I appreciated the most about
coming back to the United States is our
our government that we have three
branches of government that are supposed
to provide checks and bam
we haven't been doing a great job of
that lately but the concept of checks
and balances is important after you live
in a country where you really don't have
a lot of legal recourse you are pretty
much at the whim of the executive branch
of government in Iran and that's not a
good place to be and as an American I
didn't I of course did not feel safe
there and was not safe I was caught in
riots several times in Iran and
fortunately I was able to say you know
I'm a cattle Kohli I'm married to an
Iranian and people would pretty much
leave me alone but it wasn't a safe
situation what was your maintenance
haven straight I know has a German
American name I'm a I'm a German I am an
American mud Irish German mixture and go
back to the financial services busy what
companies can you name them that you
worked in for 20 years in both New York
and London yes and I worked for a number
of banks and investment banks including
Merrill Lynch the former Paine Webber
which became UBS for goldman sachs for a
period of time for the old Salomon
Brothers I was in Michael Lewis's the
liars poker training class that was my
first position on Wall Street for Bear
Stearns Bank of America was there a time
when you did this that you said to
yourself and I'd love to every tell us
that this is not right
we're not this business is going off
track here well in any large complex
financial business where there's a lot
of money to be made they'll always have
some jokers and the idea was the system
would punish people who went off the
rails and when I started in the business
it was a much smaller business people
knew each other people that I started
out with in business we also pretty much
know each other and people would not
pick up the phone of people who be hated
behaved bad words badly I remember
reading the biography of Andre Mayer one
of the finances that was hard frere and
somebody called him about somebody who
had not behaved well in the financial
business and he said what do you think
about him and he said I don't know him
and they said of course you know him you
worked with him and he said I don't know
him and that was the way that the bad
actors were dealt with you just shunned
them and you know so we've always had
that element in the financial services
business and it's never been very good
about punishing people in the business
but the past few years
I mention I start out my book with
meeting Warren Buffett because it was
just a good place to start but the book
isn't really about Warren Buffett it's
about the global meltdown but I used him
as a benchmark his character I talk
about that a bit in our meeting and the
way that he does business creates value
what has happened in the past few years
has destroyed value it's a whole way of
being and living in the world that's
different and I argue that creating
value is a much healthier way to invest
in a much healthier way to run the
economy but when I met Warren in August
of 2005 he had already had a bad
experience with bad lending with insane
lending I should say and with the
bankruptcy of a mobile home manufacturer
called Oakwood who issued loans that
were packaged up by Credit Suisse first
Boston and were later deemed to be value
destroying securitizations now that
happens in 2002 so it's not like the
problems that we have are new it's that
the problems that we have exploded and
they were unchecked and our government
failed to regulate and I also say in the
book that contrary to popular belief
that there was no one who could regulate
credit derivatives no one who could
regulate the system I'll say well
actually I think there was that was the
Securities and Exchange Commission we
also hear that most of the activity that
went on was not illegal and I'm here to
say well actually I'm going to raise my
hand for that one and say you might want
to rethink whether or not this was
illegal because selling securitizations
that you know are stuffed with loans
that are going to implode and yet have a
triple-a rating on them when there's
substantial principal risk and if you
sell that without explicitly explaining
that to
Buster's and you knew it or should have
known it it seems to me you might be in
violation of a few securities laws and
the SEC could have shut down these
financial meth labs that provided the
money to the mortgage lenders that kept
the party going
we could have nipped it in the bud by
shutting off the money spigot by
stopping that kind of securitization
activity and we had reason to do it and
we had reason to know we needed to do it
with precedents like the one that Warren
Buffett observed and not only that
Warren Buffett wrote about it in his
2003 shareholder letter which came out
in April of 2004 and he posted it on his
website
now when the smartest investor arguably
the smartest investor in the history of
mankind puts out a warning like that in
public signs his name on a shareholder
letter and puts it on his website why do
we the American people ignore it why is
our government ignoring it and why are
they making it easier for that activity
to go on instead of harder because many
of the actions that our government took
in intervening years made it easier for
people to do it easier to get away with
it and then to capital for bailing
people out who should have been stopping
this activity instead of you know
accelerating the activity so the average
person sits here and looks at this town
and sees that a lot of power has come
back to this town from the financial
world who how give us a tip on how you
can how you can learn to understand what
they're doing take Tim Geithner for
instance he's there's constantly he's
the secretary of the Treasury he used to
run the New York Federal Reserve Bank I
think I look at me that's a very bad
appointment why is that because Tim
Geithner has been part of the problem
and not part of the solution he's an
individual yes as an individual he's
been very closely connected with people
on Wall Street you have Jamie Dimon as
one of the on the board of the New York
Federal Reserve can guide you
Jamie Dimon runs JPMorgan he runs
JPMorgan Chase he used to be and I like
Jamie by the way and I get to that if we
have time but Tim Geithner was president
of the New York Federal Reserve you had
Hank Paulson former CEO of Goldman Sachs
who was our treasury secretary most
before Tim Geithner and Hank Paulson was
the CEO of Goldman Sachs
at the time that they were putting on
these transactions with AIG that later
became so problematic and those
contracts could have been negotiated so
that AIG didn't go under but that didn't
happen
instead everything that happened was
very much to the financial advantage of
his former employer goldman sachs he was
an interested man you might recall what
thomas paine said about interested men
he said that history has shown us that
we cannot trust interested men to just
take their scenario as a given it's very
foolish Congress should have questioned
that in fact why are we having the CEO
of a former investment bank in a
position to make decisions that are to
the advantage of the former let me give
a contrary point just for discussion
purposes you ask a man like Hank Paulson
to come in because he really understands
what's really going on oh really and
then he takes it and turns there me if
you have somebody you want sitting at
your elbow so what's really going on
here Hank Bose idea what's really going
on here this is what you got to change
well and that that is one argument but
this myth about Goldman Sachs being
better than everyone else and the best
and the brightest is similar to the AIG
Methos being the best in the brightest
and we should question how these people
came to be so exalted came to be revered
as if there are different species of
financial professional again let me stop
you if you're over in Congress and
you're fundraising and you run a
Financial Services Committee and you get
a tremendous amount of money why you
know how can well it's obvious what will
you say to that
I mean both sides they give money to
both sides yes you say that we pretty
much have a bought Congress because they
know where their money is coming from
but that's we put people into Congress
to protect our interests but that isn't
how it's
working out for us the taxpayer is
footing the bill for a lot of
malfeasance and Congress is not
questioning the malfeasance that went on
yeah I wrote here mr. Buffett in even
simpler English than I'm using today
with no graphs no charts because it's
easy to understand what went on here
when you create a lot of bad loans and
it's not just the housing market but
let's use the housing market because
that's where what most people can see
when you create a lot of bad loans in
the housing market and then pass them
off as if they're not bad loans
obviously there's a fraud going on and
now you've destabilized the housing
market a large part of the US economy
and I'm here to say that this wasn't an
innocent mistake it wasn't a math error
it wasn't a Black Swan it was the result
of black Bart's like the Californian
stagecoach robber who used to engage in
bloodless robbery and get away with it
but we've got there a lot of people that
were in this business in New York who
are revered today they gave a tremendous
amount of money to Carnegie Hall to
Cornell Medical School the president
United States Jerry Ford went on the
Citicorp board after that when Sandy
Weill was running that show Bob Rubin
was secretary of the Treasury and he's
been in a couple of those companies
goldman sachs and city and all that made
a lot of money and we've all seen that
well shouldn't we trust these people
they've been elected by the public and
you know in Bob Rubens case he was
approved by the United States Senate why
wouldn't these people be trusted well
you know there are a lot of good people
in finance but what you have here are as
I say interested men and that's why I
didn't say persons of interest although
we need some day
I said interested men in let's take the
case of Bob Rubin Bob Rubin was the
Treasury secretary under Bill Clinton
one of Bill Clinton's last acts in
office was to eliminate a restriction
and it used to be that you couldn't
lobby your old apartment for five years
Clinton got rid of that so when Enron
was about to go under you'll recall it
went bankrupt in December
2001 that fall Bob Rubin who at the time
was working for Citigroup and Citigroup
was a big creditor of Enron he called
the Treasury Department and he asked a
Treasury official if it wouldn't be to
put pressure on the rating agencies not
to downgrade Enron imagine that now what
he did was not illegal because Bill
Clinton had raised that restriction
however in my opinion it was extremely
inappropriate and you know Goldman keeps
saying how we have so much integrity
were the best the brightest and so on
let me let me take that argument further
well first of all that was just outright
inappropriate even though it wasn't
illegal and now fortunately the Treasury
Department didn't listen to that they
basically told them to go away and they
didn't they didn't pay any dignity that
the Enron went bankrupt the following
December you'll recall and Citigroup was
a creditor Bob Rubin when he made that
call with an interested man he didn't
have your interests in mind the American
taxpayers interest in mine or my
interests in mind
you had Citigroup's interest in mind how
do you find people that don't have the
public's interest in mind then to run
these things and how do you know what's
going on and remark competent because
we've had you know a lot of competent
people at the SEC who basically couldn't
find a credit derivative with a
flashlight and a map so it's not why is
that why can't they find well I think
they can but a lot of people get into
these jobs are politically connected you
know Cox was a former member of the
House of Representatives who got out of
the House of Representatives before the
door hit and on behind you know we've
had a lot of those kinds of appointment
why do you say that about well I'd
rather not get too far off topic here
but the reason I because the public is
basically drowning in credit default
swaps right derivatives when it's a
lateral and it's very simple and it's
really much simpler than that isn't it
was a lot of bad lending that was
tolerated and a lot of packaging of
those bad loans and selling them with
false labels that kept the party going
and they kept draining money
mainstream America and set us up for a
huge fall that's not hard to understand
credit derivatives were just a way of
making the problem even worse it was
sort of like throwing gasoline on the
fire but you know the fire the way the
fire was started is very easy to
understand go back these people Bob
Rubin and let's take Hank Paulson one is
I don't know those two they are now
firmly located in institutions in New
York and Washington that have a lot of
respect in the political world men that
no matter longer at Citigroup you
realized oh no no I'm not talking I'm
talking about the Council on Foreign
Relations are there Hopkins yeah let's
continue with with the Goldman mithun
and with Bob Rubin for a second after
the Enron call you know now we move fast
forward to the current problems at
Citigroup at Citigroup probably the
better solution would have been to put
Citigroup in receivership which is we
have FDIC Deposit Insurance you put
Citigroup into receivership the
shareholders are wiped out and the
people the debt holders the creditors of
Citigroup end up taking the loss and
instead we use public money to bail out
city groups creditors wow how did that
happen well that was because we started
this whole tarp program under hank
paulson who at the time was treasury
secretary former CEO of Goldman Sachs
Bob Rubin
was a former co-chair of Goldman Sachs
now if you look at Wikipedia you won't
find that fact on Wikipedia
oddly enough I don't know who writes
Wikipedia that has nothing to do with
anything but I'm just saying that a lot
of people aren't aware of that fact so
Bob Rubin was co-chair of Goldman Sachs
these were interested men now Bob Rubin
is at Citigroup Citigroup basically she
needs to go into receivership it had a
lot of problems that didn't happen
instead it got 25 billion of TARP money
in October and it didn't end there in
November we did another bailout of
Citigroup where we gave it another 20
billion dollars and guaranteed more than
300 billion in citigroup's
assets and notice what I said about
assets and what could be on citigroup's
balance sheet Reid
guaranteed it that means the US taxpayer
the US government meaning you and me and
every other US taxpayer and it didn't
end there
then at the end of February we had what
I call a non transparent or opaque
bailout of Citigroup that most taxpayers
don't even know happened because our
investment in some group was in the form
of what we call preferred shares instead
we agreed to convert it to common shares
at a price that was favorable to
Citigroup at an above market price so
that again was an additional backdoor
bail out of Citigroup as United States
ever ended today all these banks are
telling us they're making profits now
and they're better than they expected
and their stock is going up I noticed a
couple of times that in a minute we are
being lied to and I'll explain how we're
being lied to in a moment but getting
back to Bob Rubin we did all these
bailouts of Citigroup and Bob Rubin at
the time you know that City Goods needed
its first bailout so that well I didn't
know anything about CDOs
he had a reputation for being the risk
wizard a risk wizard well look if you're
in finance and you haven't been aware of
the fastest growing structured financial
product in the past few years in the
form of collateralized debt obligations
or CDOs and you are sitting on the board
of Citigroup and you're going to say
when C group needs to go into
receivership that lets bail it out and
by the way I didn't know what CDOs were
I have to say what is the best and
brightest about Goldman Sachs I don't
get it why because frankly all you have
to do is read the newspapers is stay up
to speed you know a lot of these folks
you're talking about in New York City
give a lot of money to charity I want to
go back to that for a moment does the
media and New York lay off of them
because they're giving money to all
those cultural institutions in New York
I don't know why the media in New York
is laying off of them I don't have the
answer to that good as they in the past
they gotten away with doing all this and
making all this money and then giving it
away and not being looked at closely
well they haven't been looked at closely
and they should be and it could be the
contributions I don't know I don't know
why the media that would be impressed
necessarily with charity contribution so
I don't know if that's it
or if the media needs access and they
don't want to irritate these people I
don't know what the end the media in New
York often serves on the same boards at
these people that have given money
served on it serving on the board
doesn't necessarily mean you're
compromised but there's certainly
something going on because the media
isn't nailing them the New York Times
has done pieces on Bob Rubin completely
bypassing the whole problem of
interested man and even be an interested
man he wasn't interested enough to read
the newspapers and find out about the
fastest-growing financial products that
were sitting under his own okay go back
to Tim Geithner he's there now he's the
secretary of the Treasury by the way
Larry Summers what are you thinking in
well Larry Summers was one of the
proponents of doing away with
glass-steagall and that was bipartisan
by the way it wasn't just Larry Summers
but we didn't put any handcuffs in place
to prevent the kind of thing that just
happened here so I I don't know what
Larry Summers mindset is or everything
about Larry Summers what that command
Eagle did what to watch as yes I should
explain that glass-steagall basically
allowed banks to get involved in what
used to be called investment bank
activity what I mean by that so instead
of being an FDIC insured institution
that takes some deposits from depositors
and makes loans to the local community
or do that on a big scale now you could
do things like rock and roll and start
trading credit derivatives start trading
stocks try to start doing the things
that they did before the depression that
got us into trouble and went to the
Great Depression so basically we said
let's get rid of glass-steagall and
allow banks to act as if they're goldman
sachs or bear stearns and basically have
those little mini companies going on
within the banking institution the idea
was that banks could make more money and
that they would control the risk the
reality was that the OCC the Fed in the
SEC weren't really doing much in the way
of regulation and really didn't
understand a lot of these products okay
let's go back to the average person
sitting there saying and then not worth
a lot of money and they
lost a lot in this process their 401ks
and they look is it did Bob Rubin or Tim
Geithner or Larry Summers or Hank
Paulson doing anything illegal
I don't believe that any of those
individuals did anything outright
illegal because our Congress didn't pass
laws to prevent it from happening what I
was getting at though is if you're in
their shoes they sit there and say this
is terrific I made a hundred million
dollars last year and I'm now serving my
government I'm trying to save all this
kind of stuff and this is my solution
the problem and that they've just digits
living well you have to look at the
underlying institutions that you know
Hank Paulson as an example was head of
Goldman Sachs when Goldman Sachs
alternative mortgage products was
putting out some bad products and this
has been written about Allen's flown a
fortune one a Lobel word for an article
that talked about you know residential
mortgage-backed securities packaged up
by goldman sachs alternative mortgage
products and I'm here to say that any
financial professional worth their salt
knew or should have known that a product
like that was overrated and that the
labels in no way represented the risk at
the time that they were sold if
President Obama called you to the Oval
Office and gave you
I don't care half-hour an hour and said
tell me what I should do give us give us
an idea what you would do well there is
no magic bullet answer at this point
it's gotten so far out of control that
no one has a magic bullet answer however
the things that we need to do are the
things you know getting back to prudence
finance the kinds of prudent finance
that Warren Buffett is involved in he
has a mortgage lending unit and it's
doing fine because they're prudent
mortgages 20% down no more than 36
percent of your overall debt load when
you take on the loan and so on now of
course the housing market has been hurt
because housing prices have gone down so
you know people the equity in people's
homes has been eroded we still have too
much debt and too much leverage in the
housing market but start there any new
loan you know in force those
directions certainly don't exacerbate
the problem by allowing this to go under
the bank hold on to my neighborhood bank
never had if you went to my neighborhood
right now their interest rates so low
you you know you might want to give them
the money they've never taken a risk
they've given out more easy alright what
is it about the neighborhood banks that
don't get into this kind of problem and
it's all this new york-based
operation new york washington connection
yes isn't that interesting there are a
lot of sound banks you know we have them
in Chicago as well Northern Trust is
were ready willing and stable they made
sound loans your neighborhood bank made
sound loans it's doable so we have to go
after the bad guys if we think this
won't happen again
that's just idle daydreaming we've seen
it happen again and again the S&L price
crisis drexel burnham the manufactured
housing loan market at the beginning of
this century at the end of the last
century commercial financial services
charged off credit card receivables
brought after fraud after fraud after
fraud okay you're bad we're running out
of time you're in the Oval Office and I
want your advice give me specifics of
what I can do is to save this situation
well looking at the banks now I I would
look at the distressed test with a
jaundiced eye but we may have to put
more banks into receivership
we can't keep bailing out the debt
holders of the bank just throw money
throwing money at the banks hasn't
helped when has information gonna be
coming I don't know exactly when it's
going to what does it mean they're
trying to see which banks are sound and
which aren't sound but there's been a
lot of wine going on you hear people
like well Jamie Dimon has an example
saying only 3% of mortgage loans are bad
that's extremely disingenuous 97% are
fine 3% are bad extremely disingenuous
because first of all most of that 3% is
what the problem has been if you look at
the subprime loans in 2005 2006 2007
more than 37% of the loans from 2005
2006 as of was March of last year
already 37% were delinquent meaning more
than 30 days late and
into the 2007 loans were going bad
lickety-split
if you look at the overall loan market
more than eight percent are more than 30
days late of mortgages this is horrific
by the way Jamie Dimon I don't have the
quote in front of me is saying today
this is on Thursday before the Sunday it
airs that he wants to give the
government its money back and he wish
he'd never gotten involved with the
government and wants to pay off that
loan was he what's he doing this for I
don't know why Jamie wants to give the
money back so quickly because that money
was meant to be a buffer for the bank's
if I were in his shoes I would hold on
to it now his motive and Goldman's
motive for wanting to pay back may be so
they get the government out of their
hair and they can pay their people
whatever they want but Jamie may have a
problem future with credit card debt
it's a scandal that banks are allowed to
charge people 29.9%
on credit cards in cases where people
were paying single digits they found
that to double banks are raising fees
raising interest rates on consumers
while we the american taxpayer are
giving them low borrowing costs we are
subsidizing them we have bailed them out
and they're charging you serious rates
on credit cards so the public have any
responsibility in this yes the public of
course always has responsibility but do
they have any power because we are ten
we are being taxed but we aren't being
represented well we have taxation
without effective representation when
did that last happen and when did we get
up in arms about it but the public has a
responsibility to try to borrow
prudently and to inform themselves to
the extent they can on what's going on
to write their congressmen but
unfortunately their lobbyists of one
with very little limited resources and
power but to really get on their local
congressmen and Senators and let them
know that they're outraged and that they
won't roast them for them they'll lobby
against getting them back into power if
if they don't take care of the public
interest when you're not writing books
what kind of clients do you represent
nay
some of the kinds of people we've been
talking about right here when they get
into trouble and start fighting with
each other or when they have a hairy
problem then that's the kind of business
that I get involved in give us an
example can you name some of these lives
I don't talk about my clients in public
or kneeing them but the kinds of things
as an example if they have a dispute
over securitization and they say I was
actively misled let's sit down and talk
about what happened here then the best
way is really to sit down in the room
and say okay this may have been a little
bit them it's a little bit you let's see
if we can come to a settlement during
agreement here are you are you being
hired by these big-name companies that
you've been critical of very yes only
did name companies another example is
let's say they risk on their trading
book and they don't know if their
traders are making as much money as they
expect more money than they expect or
less money than they expect because the
models are just a mishmash and they
can't really tell they're bringing in
revenue but they don't know if it's
quality revenue or risky revenue I'll
get involved in situations like that
where did this and you can put a name
you want to on it greed come from where
did the green come from where did this
wonder this happen is it always been Gus
about a million years ago when human
beings evolved that's when greens are
worse now than it used to be or the
greed has certainly allowed to remain
unchecked and you know when you get some
bad apples in they tend to draw more bad
apples and and you know the reason this
happened now and the way that it
happened is these products exploded and
herring exploded so you know if you had
a bad core group at one of these
investment banks they would start
funding hedge funds and other people and
once you had a group together it became
like Halawa in the Middle East the way
of transferring money around so nobody
can tell what's going on now you had a
bunch of people who are basically in on
it with you so you know you had a guy
from Merrill Lynch was on the board of
ownit mortgage lending in California can
hardly say that's arm's length and they
were originating a lot of mortgages
the head of Dallas the head of the CEO
of on it was saying I could paid more
for a no documentation loan and for
documentation alone and it's a classic
situation for fraud and Merrill Lynch
was also packaging up some of those
assets as were other investment banks
they were lending to them when they went
under as far as I'm concerned it was
game over at the end of 2006 there was
no deniability for CEOs anymore they
should have shut this activity down
within their investment things and they
didn't because they knew that people
wouldn't understand what was going on
most Americans wouldn't understand most
congressman congressman wouldn't
understand and they could get away with
it so they accelerated that activity
what are the chances that these big
companies these big New York race
companies or the political institutions
in this town will clean up the writing
well so far they've gotten away with the
largest Ponzi scheme in the history of
the capital market or worse they've
gotten away with the journal money yeah
it Dwarfs what Madoff did so far they've
indicted two former hedge fund managers
one of them I know Ralph Cioffi from
Bear Sterns that's chump change that's
nothing and you know even that may be
difficult to prove whether or not
anything was done wrong with respect to
those investors I don't know what
representations that they made directly
I wasn't in the meeting room but with
respect to what was going on in the rest
of the industry and here to say that the
you know so far they've gotten away with
a Ponzi scheme that has taken down our
housing market then has contaminated our
municipal bond insurance business so
that it's harder for us to raise money
for water pipes and things that we need
to get done this has been a huge crime
on the American economy and so forth
people aren't being held accountable and
we're bailing out a lot of bad guys no
no questions asked in some cases we have
to recapitalize the financial system but
the money that was thrown in has you
know been like throwing water on sand
because we really needed to put some of
these institutions into receivership